hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video and today we're going to be
talking about some of the posts on
reddit talking about a new blackout and
I also want to hear some of your
opinions on some of these other posts
now before I get started regarding
yesterday's video thank you all for the
great comments or just review a couple
days ago this video and I just want to
say that I am still sick so if my voice
doesn't sound is great or is clear and
the cuts are kind of bit awkward I'm
sorry I'm practically coughing like
every minute I try to do this so I do
apologize for that but regardless let's
just get right into this so Olivia n
reddit there's been a lot of posts about
another four on our blackout and if you
are uninformed about this so-called
blackout it was a community event we
hosted around the middle of season one
where basically the whole community on
reddit picked one date and didn't play
the game for an entire 24 hours thus
lowering the player numbers and
basically telling you be self they need
to listen to us or we're going to stop
playing your game Ubisoft then
eventually came out with a post on
Reddit stating that they're going to
start listening to us and the community
more often and come up with better
updates and content so everyone decided
to cancel the blackout because we
succeeded in our goal which was to get
the devs to listen to us someone on
reddit is trying to start another
blackout and try to do the same thing
once again last week on the dev stream
they had a bunch of members from the
community and top-tier players who were
invited to the studio in Montreal where
they do the dev stream to be on the
stream and check out some of the
behind-the-scenes content coming and
like season 3 also season 2 all the
other stuff they have planned the people
invited weren't allowed to tell anyone
what they saw but one person on reddit
by a name of iris dice did mention that
there are a ton of people working on the
game and that they're clearly on the
cuvee understand the frustration that
we're going through and want nothing
more than this game to succeed he also
states that the game development isn't
exactly an easy thing to do especially
if your game is a triple-a title then
you have to meet all these certain
expectations such as making sure the
graphics look great its fluid and smooth
gameplay with little to no bugs and so
many other types of expectations it's
tough for companies to do that although
some can pull them off that's not all of
them can that's exactly what game
development is so difficult anyway he
goes on to say that the devs care deeply
about what we have to say and that
they're aware of the balance issues of
the characters and the connection issues
everybody's been having recently facing
issues takes time
des can't just wave a magic wand around
and wish for everything to work properly
so yes I know it's probably a bad idea
but I do kind of side with the devs and
in a way they're kind of right now do I
wish that it could be faster and the
connection issues could be fixed by
tomorrow of course I do everybody would
want that but it's not going to happen
that's just the sad truth of it the
second post today was by a reddit user
named damn no HTML or Scott June Scott
June is a really good Dark Souls player
who's competed in the very highest level
of PvP possible and has since moved onto
for honor if you've watched the stream
of the season 2 premiere on on the
stream on May 15 he was in that
tournament I believe he was in Group C
and he states that he develops into
began and displayed Dark Souls 3 most of
all from what he's played Dark Souls 3
most of all of them and the PvP in Dark
Souls 3 was absolutely horrible the meta
of the game consisted of a weapon called
the car cart this curved sword any of
you Dark Souls players you already know
and understand it but basically it's
this really fast curved sword weapon
that basically outmatched every weapon
in the game and then it was boring to
watch tournaments because of the boring
and stale gameplay that I had because it
was the meta but the community never had
a blackout or anything like that they
couldn't even communicate with the devs
because of the developers being from
Japan and not really understanding
English even though after all that
though yet the community was still
stable
Scott believes that it's the community
that's the problem and not necessarily
the devs the devs constantly do listen
to us and even invite some of the best
players around to give us feedback on
patches and then discuss what's wrong
with them I mean come on if you're going
to have someone discuss to you it'd
rather be the best players in the game
that play the game for a living and they
know what they're doing
so the problem Scott has is that the
devs are just taking their time and
going slow without with fixing
everything the next post has to deal
with the article that kind of came up on
get hype and basically it states that
for honor now has lost 95% of its player
base which was worse than the division
one year ago now a lot of people were
trying to debunk this and one guy kind
of set it right correctly that there is
not 95% 95% of the player bases not left
okay they only can get the numbers from
steam because the council numbers have
been disabled on on the game and plus
yourself doesn't release them either but
steam automatically has them up so
he might have it for the website might
have been looking at the steam records
of people playing and then on top of
that I guess this guy has been looking
around asking some questions and I guess
there's been a lot of posts regarding
the players saying that there's been
over 80,000 people on council hundred
thousand people on council even like 40k
on PC so clearly these numbers aren't
accurate and I believe this article is
very misleading and then finally the
last posted date of the today was by a
Reddit user named Emily Smith 31 and to
basically sum up her posts because I
feel like this video is getting too long
as it is basically she states that the
reason why the connection really hasn't
been fixed in this game is because we
constantly barrage the devs with balance
ideas on top of the connection issues so
basically the devs are overwhelmed with
things to fix and they're going to be
doing the character balances first
because we're constantly demanding it so
often instead of the connection issues
which in my opinion the connectors are
way more important I want to know your
opinion on all these posts who you agree
with who you disagree with and I want to
hear your opinions too all these posts
are going to be in the description if
you want to see the full whole lengthy
paragraphs of all three posts instead of
the summary I just gave but anyway guys
that's all it's going to be all it is
for me today if you did like the video
please give it a like if you disliked it
the dislike button if you're new then
subscribe for more on our content and of
while you're at it click the bell next
to it so you could be notified in my
note when I upload a video so you never
miss a video of mine and then you can
also click the annotation in the top
right to be taken to my previous video
and then thank you all for watching guys
and I'll see you in the next video cuz I
guess